[Aplausos]
cuando yo era chico mi padre corría en
el motocross
también arreglaba las motos de sus
amigos que corrían con él en casa y me
había hecho una motito chica para que yo
anduviera él me llegaba
esa moto para las carreras los domingos
sobre todo y yo andaba ahí entre entre
los corredores molestando y eso yo no
no creo que les hacía muchas gracias nos
vemos corredores que yo molestará con mi
moto
mi abuelo por parte de madre él era
repostero él cuando era chico dentro de
mandadero en el chajá era de él era de
paysandú
cuando el chajá abrió la primera fábrica
aquí en montevideo él se vino de
encargado para esa fábrica
y genera bastante emprendedor el fundo y
fundió varias fábricas y panaderías
y fábricas de postres en mi otro abuelo
por parte de padre
él era comerciante él básicamente lo que
hacía era comprar quesos madurarlos eso
se llama afinador y después venderlos en
mi casa había
un depósito lleno de estanterías de
madera hasta el techo repletas de queso
y una de las travesuras que me gustaba
hacer cuando era chico dicen que hacía
muchos pero no sé si sería cierto era
entrar a ese depósito cuando mi abuelo
dormía la siesta y con el calador que es
un instrumento que es como un medio caño
que se introduce en el queso y se hace
girar y se saca como un cilindro de
queso yo me comí a ese queso y tapaba de
nuevo de nuevo el queso no pero mi
abuelo siempre se daba cuenta de vida de
forma corría por todo parte del plata
también en otra cosa que me gustaba
hacer mucho cuando cuando era niño era
llegar de la escuela sobre todo los días
los días de otoño lluviosos y era
sacarme la túnica y salir a adjuntar
hongos y después mi madre los cocinaba
y también tenía mucho contacto con la
naturaleza siempre desde el niño porque
salíamos mucho a acampar con mi familia
y en esos campamentos yo me hacía mi
propio jueguito como le dicen en campaña
de fueguitos de matero un poquito
chiquito y ahí me cocinaba se había
pescado algún bien todo me lo menos
cocinado en ese jueguito o alguna rana
que había casado o también alguna liebre
tenía obsesión por hacer llover a las
brasas que siempre quedaban resecas pero
1 en la vida
va buscando sus destinos y tiene que
trabajar trabajar en algo y yo cuando
era joven para trabajar elegí la
mecánica así fue que con 20 años con un
amigo nos fuimos para san luís y abrimos
un taller de motos trabajé 20 años como
mecánico reparando motos pero siempre me
gustó la cocina de muy chico cuando era
cuando era chico miraba la cordon bleu
en el canal en el canal 5 después de más
de grande miraba agoniza la barry y
roberto esperanza y yo intentaba
hacer las recetas que ellos hacían
reproducir esos platos y lo que lograba
era este resultado espantoso realmente
si esto lo hubiera hecho siendo el
cocinero profesional no lo mostraría
la verdad que no era no era bueno capaz
que algo estaba rico pero no no era muy
no era muy profesional mi trabajo en ese
entonces pero sí hubo una persona que me
cambió la cabeza me hizo ver que había
había otra forma de interpretar la
cocina que no era hacer lo que estaba
escrito o reproducir lo que otros hacían
sino era crear su propia su propia
cocina él ya falleció hace unos años muy
joven esa persona fue
juan pablo calderón
el negro
y después en el 2007 se inaugure un
taller nuevo estaba todo impecable era
como un laboratorio a su vez es el mismo
año escuchando la radio yo soy medio
radio maníaco me gusta mucho escuchar
radio
y me entero que hay un seminario de
cocina en punta del este
aromas y sabores que entre muchos de los
cocineros que venían venían dolli
irigoyen y osvaldo gross y ahí me fui
hacia asia punta del este- de ese
seminario
y ese fue mi primer paso al lento camino
de convertirme en un cocinero después
hice un taller de cocina
con marcelo borneo un curso de arte en
caramelo con claudia de razón un curso
de cocina de vanguardia con esteban
brilloso
y estudie lees y varios libros de cocina
y de recetas y entrevistas a cocineros
hay mucha información en internet seguía
asistiendo a varios seminarios de ese
estilo como desde sudamérica
y
y todas esas cosas y trabajar en algún
evento y hacer temporada de punta del
este como cocinero
como las dos cosas tenía el taller
todavía pero si algún evento como
cocinero
y eso me fue como perdiendo el miedo a
cocinar yo me estresaba me estresaba
mucho cocinando aunque fuera para para
mí
para mariela y para mí para mi compañera
o para algunos amigos era sufría mucho
estrés cuando cocinaba no estaba seguro
de lo que hacía y así fue que en 2013
con una amiga abrimos un restaurant en
cuchilla alta ese restaurant duró una
temporada esa sociedad como muchas
sociedades dura un poco
y en noviembre de 2014 abrimos macachín
siempre con el apoyo de mariela que
siempre en la posición está en esta
locura de macachín y mis sobrinos enanos
que trabajo
muchos muchos días cuando digo muchos
son muchos días sin cobrar
al principio fue muy difícil no venía ni
el loro del restaurante imagínense un
restaurant que dice
macachín cocina uruguaya creativa
nosotros nos pensaríamos que pensaría la
gente que quiere decir cocina uruguaya
creativa ustedes también se los deben
pensar y yo al principio no encontraba
las las palabras para definir que era la
cocina uruguaya creativa que era lo que
yo hacía después de a poco fui como como
redondeando una idea y cocina uruguaya
creativa es cocinar con productos
uruguayo es cocinar con lo que nos da la
naturaleza en ese en ese momento en esa
época del año es cocinar con el producto
de nuestros productores orgánicos es
usar la pesca artesanal de nuestros
pescadores
también es ofrecer lo que yo quiero dar
no lo que el otro demanda
y también es encontrar el alma de
recolector que llegó dentro siento que
tengo alma de recolector nosotros
recolectamos cerca de 100 especies para
el restaurant
y da mucho trabajo ser el recolector y
cocinero a la vez ahí es en esa foto lo
que estamos recomendando son totoras
seguramente tengo
la pierna por la mitad de barro y agua
la tutora crece en bañados
y requiere mucha mucha investigación
este tipo de cocina de recolección hay
que investigar antes sobre todo en
bibliografía
hay que investigar después de recolectar
qué hacemos con ese producto que
recolectamos
si sirve para tal cosa si sirve para
lota si nos gusta si no nos gusta a
veces también mucha investigación hay
porque a veces encontramos algo que
puede tener potencial gastronómico que
puede ser rico que puede servir para
algo pero en realidad no sabemos si es
comestible así que el nivel de toxicidad
tiene y ahí hay que investigar
y les voy a explicar un poquito el
proceso
creativo de la cocina de macachín y les
voy a explicar por qué para mi la cocina
empieza en el cerebro
1 desde que nace hasta que muere va
acumulando información en su cerebro
acumula la información de su entorno
acumula recuerdos que tiene acumula
sabores olores aromas texturas
sensaciones
y con todo eso uno se va armando ideas
en la cabeza en este caso yo para hacer
platos de cocina uno agarra una naranja
y sabe que la naranja sabe el color que
tiene sabe que el aroma está en la
cáscara
sabe que si la corte tiene jugo sabe que
ese jugo es más ácido o más dulce
dependiendo de la variedad de la época
del año se hizo frío si no hizo frío
sabe que la cáscara es amarga y con toda
esa información como si fuera una
melodía musical donde una nota armoniza
con la otra uno va creando la idea del
plato en la cabeza donde todo tiene que
tener cierta armonía y sintonía
el proceso creativo
de la cocina de macachín
es el siguiente en este caso se trata de
una deconstrucción es una manera muy
fácil de crear platos a través de una
deconstrucción se elige generalmente un
plato de cocina tradicional en este caso
es un guiso de lentejas y después se
juega con las texturas las temperaturas
las técnicas de cocción el emplatado
también el agregado de algún producto
que no está necesariamente en esa receta
original como en este caso que tiene que
tiene manzana
pero hay algo muy importante en este
tipo de creaciones de platos es que no
se puede perder el alma del plato cuando
yo pruebo este plato me tiene que
recordar en algún momento que lo que
estoy comiendo es un guiso de lentejas
otra de las formas de crear es bastante
fácil y me divierte mucho me gusta jugar
mucho con las texturas de los productos
y es varían las texturas de un producto
en este caso es un plato con quesos ahí
tenemos varias texturas de quesos hay
una espuma una crema un crocante un
queso fundido y una gelatina rayada de
queso
la siguiente manera de crear son los
recuerdos de la infancia uno recuerda
que comía cuando era chico que le
gustaba que no le gustaba también
recuerda que no le gustaba de chico y
que le gusta ahora y con esos recuerdos
uno puede volver atrás a su infancia y
crear platos en este caso es un postre
chajá nosotros lo llamamos postre nevado
porque es una de las tantas marcas que
fundó que fundó mi abuelo
después la la siguiente manera de crear
es un poco más trabajosa pero me gusta
me gusta mucho eso de indagar y es
investigar en la historia
tanto sean libros de historias libros de
cocina viejos en relatos de la historia
viejo en este caso es una lengua a la
arpillera con ajo silvestre el ajo
silvestre es uno de los tantos
productos que recolectamos para cocinar
en macachín pero les cuento un poquito
la historia de la lengua a la arpillera
cuando cuando los autos mataban una vaca
lo primero que hacían era cortarle la
ley en sacar la lengua y cocinarla al
rescoldo o sea directamente sobre las
brasas y se la hice la se la comían así
nosotros en macachín no tenemos la
posibilidad de usar esa técnica porque
no tenemos donde hacer fuego no tenemos
ni parrilla ni nada pero si conociendo
la técnica de envolver una carne en un
trapo en este caso arpillera
me imaginé que tendría que quedar
bastante parecido a lo que es la lengua
al rescoldo haciendo una lengua con la
técnica de la arpillera y de hecho queda
después hay otros platos que
que no sé cómo los creo simplemente se
me ocurren me vienen la combinación de
ideas y de texturas y de combinación de
sabores a la cabeza y salen muchas veces
esas ideas pasan a un papel y después se
cocinan y van a un plato y muchas veces
directamente de la cabeza pasa al plato
nunca lo escribo y eso a veces me fue a
través de un problema porque después lo
quiero reproducir y no me acuerdo ni ni
cómo era pero pero es así pero si hay
algo que tengo muy claro y es que el día
que deje de crear dejo de cocinar muchas
gracias